for coming for the last day of boot camp
who started something monthly if you
second make sure about much loss okay so
welcome back and so as you remember last
time I gave it sort of an overview of
stuff of like how this three concepts a
little power flows optimization max flow
connect oh I didn't really talk about
optimization much this will change in
this lecture and what this gave the
drone the the general picture and here
what we will do today we will try to
finally see some actual action there and
just think about how can we use the
different flows to approximate the max
flow mean under the drugs so that is a
quick just as a quick reminder so the
product you are trying to solve is the
maximum flow problem in which we
essentially are looking for the
feasibility flow maximum value so I feel
blessed if flow is the one that
satisfies flow conservation constraints
so no leaks at vertices other than SMT
and doesn't overcome an arc so they
float on an exit most this quantity and
what you want to maximize the value
which is just the amount of stuff that
we send from s to T okay and just before
I continue I just want to make one
important point so last time I gave you
the you know sort of the the history of
max flow problem but while doing this
because of editing by deleting slides I
forgot about one important result so I
said well what I was talking about this
I said that essentially this is the
state of the art for the max flow
problem but as of last year this is not
really true anymore so there is a
beautiful result of fleance it fort who
actually are able to like get rid of
this trade-off and sort of and get the
right behavior on the sparsity so
essentially now the running time is the
best running and for max flows and
square root of n as opposed to mean of
these two things
okay so this is always better than this
this of course doesn't change the sparse
graph picture but definitely you know
changes the picture of the mass flow so
essentially it's still we have the
barrier of n to the 3 halves here but
now at least we have sort of right
dependence of the sparsity
like this is the dependence path that we
expected all along and for 40 years we
couldn't get it now this guy's finally
did it okay
and interestingly enough you know some
of his tools okay I will talk about this
in the third lectures okay so this is
just and now they as I explained that
well I just said it now explained last
lecture sort of what we'll focus on
today is just trying to like forget for
a moment about the directed max flow and
an exact solutions we just want to get
and one night such an approximate
solution to max flow in undirected
graphs but you want to again and just
beat the SN to the three halves about
using a logical flow okay and that's
what today's lecture will be about and
essentially some of the concepts and
idea that we show up here will then be a
bit refined and somehow combined with
some bigger hammers to actually get the
what the exact Maxwell result for
directed graphs and sort of the
interesting thing is that you know after
you see bees and what I will be talking
about this in the third lecture today
then essentially you realize that some
of the philosophy that is that came up
in this in terms of this problem is
essentially implement again in this in
this in this exactly that's it okay so
that's that's why we are talking about
so many okay
so this is the plan and by the way are
there any questions about anything I
said last time just say feel free
quicker okay so of course as I said we
really come frozen this again is just a
quick reminder what to do because rows
flow are at least what is the most
convenient definition from our point of
view and from our point of view
analytical flows are just corresponds to
minimizing able to help
musician over the space of flop and has
already we very well know we could
compute the cash flows extremely fast
mean linear time okay so this is just
okay and so let's just talk about the
algorithm so last time I gave you the
blurring of stuff what is the general
halfway of the algorithm so rough it is
a very simple iterative procedure when
we start with trading away we will
always treat our edges as resistors with
some corresponding resistances and in
each radius resistance will be one and
then you know what we will do will just
repeat the following group so we just
compute a logical flow which was of the
of the prescribed value F star so f star
is the value of mass flow that we as
soon as we know
so we computed that the cash flow refers
to the kind of distances we look at this
flow and you know we know that the flow
conservation constraints will be always
preserved but the problem will be that
some of the if some of the edges might
be throwing too much and what we will do
will increase resistances on this over
Frank edges in some way and then we will
repeat and we hope that we will converge
in some way I stood up to many
iterations okay so this is the general
outline and it can be more it can be
made work and sort of you know what
again this is just an outline you
actually have to be very careful about
how we instantiate different details of
this algorithm and that's what we will
do today okay okay so you know how to go
about filling in these blanks
well just a reminder I already said it
that you know we are dealing with
undirected graphs so let's forget about
the erected graphs that they exist for
the sake of the scope of this talk and
also we assume that all the capacities
are one that the graph is sparse and
again that the value of too much flow is
no okay so how will how to go about
today feeling in these blogs and somehow
the part of stuff here is just the
following interesting observation okay
so if I fix the resistances are my graph
and I compute this electrical flow of
value starting this graph well then
clearly I don't expect this illogical
flow to obey all the constraints okay I
don't I really expect that at least for
at least one edge it will be true that
the flow on this edge will be much
bigger than 1 which is the
which is the capacity okay so that's
definitely does I think is something I
can expect however even though the
electrical flow will violate some
capacity constraints it still preserves
the capacity of stress in some much
weaker cells but still some important
sense maybe what you can prove is the
case is that no matter what the
resistances are then if I look and if I
look at this it if I look at the
extension which essentially you can once
you divide it by the sum of the
resistances of website so if you will
what you will get on the left is just
the expected overflow when the
expectation or the average overflow when
the average is taken up two resistances
then this average overflow will be at
most one so it will be at most you know
what we expect it to be okay so again
this the fact that the average overflow
is good doesn't mean that all the edges
are like that no edges overflow and the
indeed what will happen it's very often
that there will be adjusting that
overflow a lot but the average will
always be okay no matter is let's see
you go this way okay so essentially this
is just awaiting I just want to commit
some weighted average of the combination
of the order clause and you know as long
as we compute energy can flow rates for
instance is lose weight it always took
the case but this average of this
average later this average over flow
will be good even though some individual
arts in visual errors might crawl it so
this is and in a sense you know by just
made is the observation we can view as a
different flows as a fast way of solving
the following very you know we
convention of maximal questions we call
like feasibility on average when
essentially we are even some weights W
and our goal is just to find the flow of
value star that has no not the Fazzio
all the overflows
all the flow all the personnel at most
one but this doesn't help that this this
average weighted flow to be a poser
so just this is our path we don't care
about the video edges we just want to
make sure that the average is always
okay so for that you got from ours it's
perfect
they just solve they just solve the
problem in what chalk you just you know
you just just take the weights to be
good resistances any political or when
you get okay so you know of course this
is a very this is every week this is a
very weak problem but the surprising
thing is that even though this is a very
weak way of sewing like they believe
excessive nutrients oh [ __ ] smoke on
this issue so this problem is already
useful to us and actually already allows
us to get the idea that we actually more
actually it's actually more okay so
section allows us to take this crude
algorithm and turn it into definitely
actually another actually actually want
he's called to be good ugly and sort of
it's it's one of the things that I guess
was written discovered and rediscovered
a couple of times throughout the history
so it's a I think as liquid to the
saying you know the discovery system is
it but then the one who would be present
last time and I think the last time is
this stems from the workers of Freud's
appear which appear on the composting
and then plot ich weiß titles like the
this sort of move this in this paradigm
more to the optimization the ascetic and
then there's a fairness survey by Aurora
has on and Khalid where they spoke very
nicely put it together and now say
Pericles saying by the way that's a very
already thought this actually used to be
optimization
actually I think that you like this
definitely like there is a couple of
East Asia or this idea was discovered
because it's one of this beautifully
simple ideas yeah then there was the
distributed we also discovered
independently so exactly I said I didn't
even try to like I know that at least
for like some of the economics
technically it was forgotten even in the
community I think that they discovered
in this was from anything the community
that they saw that relies only on after
the fact when they saw it again in this
I think of experts that oh we knew this
before right
so okay so I guess because indeed this a
like this is probably a very you know
very beautiful it's about you if you
didn't rediscover my exit people don't
bother to say oh this is the
distribution they just so my kid in
there as a factory but it's a very good
friend very easy okay
so essentially the way you can think
about this technique is just a technique
for turning with algorithms into
stronger ones okay so in our setting the
way it works is that we take this could
algorithm that is computing this like
the Sony excusable average max flow
problems as a black ghost
is what a certain approximation
algorithm for the maximum product so
we're sort of we turn the feasibility on
average into physically into approximate
feasibility of everywhere okay and this
is a very generic way and well the
question is how can you do this magic
and dignities sounds mysterious now but
once you see the tricks you see the
power continues it isn't how how much it
is in the end so what do we do well I'd
like the idea is the product the way we
will construct our our feasible
everywhere almost visible everywhere max
flow insight repeatedly querying this
could algorithm two different ways okay
so essentially here is our black book
that if demand response is crude
algorithm and we will maintain some ways
which means I will all be equal to one
okay and then we'll just play the
following game so Volga's we'll take our
weights were send it to the food ad with
Morocco and it can give us soft robot
okay so what we know about the strong we
know that the force is a flow understand
and also that is feasible
on average specific to the way that we
provide so we will get some flow and
then based on this flow we will update
our await somehow and then we have
anyway so we were sent this weights
again to look at algorithm which will
again give us so come back and then
we'll look at this new flow around a
tower of power our weights based on that
keep doing this for some other
situations and now the way we will get
power our know our flow that is actually
feasible like everywhere it's almost
visible everywhere it just will take an
average of all the flows that we have
seen that we never returned from school
so we will not look at any particular
flow in return we actually take the
average for everything disease so that's
day so that's the way the visitor alarms
life and of course the crucial step here
is you know how do we update weights to
make it work okay
so imagine that we are somebody this
procedure so we have another cup we have
our current weights WI minus 1 we
service we supplied it to our algorithm
we get some throwback and now how do we
get thing of the next iteration of
weights well what we just do we just
look at each each of the weights which
corresponds to the edges of the graph
and what we do while we do it
multiplicative updated and hence the
name of the items so essentially we
multiply each weight by 1 plus epsilon
times the flow on this edge in this flow
and I returned and organized by row I
when Rho I is just the maximum
congestion in in current body i
specially generated maximum flow on edge
that this flow and I have okay the
reason why we want but why we are
introducing this normalization you just
want to make sure that this update is a
number between 1 okay so we don't want
this the evolution of weights to be too
drastic groups won't explain and that's
the way when we normalize the
non-disclosed here this will be always
something more to it folks excel so the
quality
okay so this is the way the weights are
the weights are evolving and now the
other light than that means that makes
it small the work is just the following
so if you have an edge that suffers a
lot over flow between some iteration
then clearly its weight will be
multiplied by one bathroom tile okay so
we let's say the the overflow is getting
close to maximum so each way this title
so essentially if so if so edge suffers
in a lot of trouble to offer the needs
its way to will just skyrocket after
some time because you'll get exponential
growth in it but ahead we know that each
of the strokes is feasible on average
and using that you know so we know that
they are cover from is small so for the
average increase of weight is pretty is
pretty modest so we particularly we look
at how this sum of all the ways no it
grows look the function and now once we
have this proclamation so what we know
is that you know if there was so edge
that suffers that overflow to open then
what its way to skyrocket but we know me
transparent because we know that the
cause some of the weights
doesn't increase too much so we can just
maybe get something but it's out of this
and what we they conclude that we get
out to that is that's certainly no H
there is no H in our graph that suffers
that over from effect okay every edge
can suffer overflow from time to time
but there is no edge of consistently is
getting clear / - okay
and once now we take an average of
multiples in the end then essentially
for every individual edge this
occasional large overflow they will just
will be averaged out there sort of the
are recovered or re will not be factored
in this way that's roughly the whole
idea this is the whole idea behind this
method now we have to do someone to
prove it and
when you do this then then what you will
get and again this is just a survey that
provided to this is called they are not
the first one to come up is not but this
is one place to just keep it up then
essentially you will notice that once
you take roughly Rho over epsilon
squared iterations of this method then
this average will always prefer milk
response 2 into 1 minus epsilon
proximity proximity sensor goes will
happen is that the overflow of each
action bit more focus epsilon which will
be then you can just divide by one for
subset 1 plus epsilon 3 will get the
field will flow that I choose yes hope
you have to divide it's given like well
if you everything I said is for
commodities when you have considered you
don't like these things by Costas it's
looking to develop this condition okay
and just like okay this this row here is
just a maximum of overflow that we have
our market so it's actually new way to
think about this room is roughly it's
roughly a measure you know how much the
answers of our crew algorithm in this
case you know it is the electric power
like in our case is the electrical
electrical
propagation how much different it is
from the actual mass flow rate this is
the measure of similarity it's like when
Rho is close to 1 then power the answers
written by our Oracle are actually
essentially max flows so we expected
hostile competitors if there are very
nice friends
then we expect our competitors in
particular it's not hard to see that
this V near the tennis overall is
unavoidable okay because what happens is
that if there's even one edge that
suffers an overflow over from there just
averages out is that we have to divide
by another big enough like comparable to
rock because it is soft to be something
close
yes in a sense what you are doing like
that's what they said that positive on
this abyss to be smooth enough like what
you really are doing case you are trying
to like this pivot sides like so like I
think that there is a perfect equation
which that you can write that this is
trying to approximate by this element
okay so that's exactly sort of that's
the reason why probably is like I would
need to think about it but I should I'm
sure that's it's yes I just don't know
what to take what is an equation is
because exactly like that's why we need
this like smoothness parameter and if
you smoke this approximation to be like
the only way to be able to be roughly to
the sum of all the overflows which we've
seen so far and essentially I think
comes will take the absolute to be the
limit in zero you will get so I think I
forgot the name of it there's something
in that they call this so the other
thing that reminds me is that for John
star it sure looks like these are
LaGrant multipliers or something and
you're doing Esav and that if you can
lessen the instance you're adding them
all together you're doing something like
they Jeb each a polynomial of the things
or something is there some way to
rewrite this little thing I don't know
but maybe you get a better answer if you
did right then you get ridiculous - you
know that's a good question thank you
for
yeah can you get a better like so for
this competitors it's not idea that if
you could get one over external
convergence you know okay so first of
all night because as far as I remember
that does for this frame anyway I said
the different building is a black ghost
and like many things out of the black
box I think it is domestic in here but
they're also some way to think of the
waves is some kind of a garage
multiplier yes there so I says how do
you like your choice now that certainly
the way they phrase it is it's just
about situation okay so yes this way
it's not really represent my go-to place
yet because that's who and I become a
nice just think of it that way or
another
so maybe and by us
hey I I like I like this this point of
view like integrating again like Rakesh
my standards like they they take
perspective I think it's
yes yes like okay so I think well you
are we might have been any capacities
head the or so by the way this framework
works even though there is nothing about
other chakras if you dislike it just for
an Oracle that just gives you this like
after it's really good on average this
will work so there is nothing like
unless you can throw everything else
company you okay
and also the initial energy is Havana
Cuba okay so essentially if you like
solving this minimization and if you
Department is Maxwell also this is the
horoscope and that's what all you think
you this athletes do not really
correspond to that is that now because
you forget about where is this it will
actually report it again later
for now we are forgetting where this
process are coming from all we know
about them is the deal is good there are
physical other change if there is no
quadratic form that I can see that you
are minimizing
yes and you can - yes so essentially you
can laughter - yes so well you can also
view this you can get this feat also by
are like well taking essentially grid in
the same after you remember asking
smooth flutter can shock me like there
are many points of view okay the
veterans position I think if you don't
have an instruction like any handle the
structure of the problem I know you can
do better like I think you would need
you like the point is have if you are
just dealing with our blacks this just
ascended the generals sending this works
for is when you know when your visible
face just expects only two bodies that
give you this are very very nice it's
like there are nothing crow what if you
come across actually we will take
advantage like to bathe with rebounds
will take a punch with the fact that
this marker is not powerful sexuality
flow then we will use so the information
without a problem you see it today but
for now you know if I just think about
this tough and very complex both an
architrave Oracle that gives you this
feasible average associates this is
investment it's not great this second
also because your average all the
solutions like you have seen it like the
Lawrence's presentation is that you are
also staking averages like so this is
actually this is a the nice little
accusations that you can cast all of
these things like there are be like use
it
in addition actually allows you to like
to juice like you and every you spend a
second year to just the questions what
does the space to move sort of
motivation what is your life but I don't
really get second order method you
needed to do something more than just
keep around your last thing you did
chebychev or some other yes yes is that
the country great
yes but this is not doing [ __ ] just this
is what you are averaging him so you're
doing something I think like there are
questions from the holy Qur proving a
statement about convergence of the
average which usually if you think it
like what may be nice is to come up with
is not evolution that just itself
converges to direct services because the
thing is that usually like if you if you
want to clear some converters Muslim see
also on some sequence you know yes one
way of doing this instead of reasoning
or the sequence is reasoning about
contenders of it of the averages but
usual integrals of the average is slower
and the convention like the data
converters but if you were able to get
that process here that makes this closer
to get contacts with the right solution
and actually you know this would be a
cute break you because then you can play
tricks like taking epsilon to be
one-half you know getting some solution
then you know how doing their fill and
doing more naturally I think you like
this would be a very powerful tool but
no such things it's not and I think
that's exactly for this to work you
would need to have some other
information about okay I mean the whole
approach here is effectively working
with residuals right so you're not only
the average that makes sense right if
that loss function were a quadratic for
instance names exactly the residuals you
know I'm saying you will need to make
if you were able to get again in this in
this general framework of we know of
that you know you just get this Oracle
that's this coming from somewhere that
you have no idea where you don't know
this context her linear solid okay so
this is so this is the metals and now
then what is the bottom line for us is
that essentially our religion of
procreative gives us such an incantation
event of a yes yes well this is I guess
this is just cleaner this way to analyze
I think nothing was really what if he
gets nothing really but happened the
actual of instances no nothing would
happen if you just like this update you
just know let the sky think of any
updates for things that are not close to
but are not close to being separated
because you really would here able to
combat these situations because you take
average in Indian so if they look at the
iterations in which it was far from the
close to capacity the sister you can
just have another issue anymore for this
you are counting one way and then for
the other serving the argument and what
if you would actually difference between
so you might get a negative you might be
reduced
yes also by many ways so here we are
using the fact that sort of we can only
wear what we only have losses you don't
have billions you can also accept this
table to the casement when you have both
losses and gains but then actually your
convergence analysis itself any
quadratically on they will do we and
again I think this also is provably so I
think you don't like okay this all goes
back to this next paper and for reaching
of this the container to get here
essentially let's open up lesbos Aurora
and how they are doing it this is
retested and instance of the Express
program and then first of all we know
high power density transfer over okay
the black box is solving a minimization
very concept here the sex with her again
so the the a there is solving a
minimization problem where if you
increase the effective resistance is but
costs a factor of n all right it's the
same problem yeah so like well if you if
you scale everything by a doesn't matter
it's like you don't care about us and
not about the car you do this right you
know like I think does it better so the
point is that actually ok so what's
happening here like people do it with
one electrode like this minus one and
absolute value of that actually was
significant better than plus you can
refine the analysis of this game versus
you can trade what really matters is it
is really you know how much like you
multiplying or how much is their leaf in
one direction a direction rather
direction is its small so to see war but
like again like this moving get anything
better and doesn't complicate the
picture they said this is well actually
later on we will it's really important
to either actually this obviously
it's just you know it's in any case you
can think that like what is a maximum
exposure is an infinity deviation which
for this we will just want to minimize
like you want to party this like send
SSI either flow that's very cool
like making the largest capacity based
as possible so another and they throw
this bathroom of course do you know that
you don't have to control my view and if
it was not for you so we just are
televising for coming and it just it's
unfair but still the guys who don't
throw too much art and not as much less
than you guys for a little so you're
actually computing something stronger
your computing them a command energy max
flow ok I still the same I'm not sure
even how to make it precise it's gonna
cramming if it may actually be unique
there may be some for them it's a
promise to taking averages which both
work well with quadratic relation right
so I don't see that you can like into
the biggest export of your my flow will
be will tend to be a bit more like
cheaper and their choice then you know
maybe the worst max flow that we can
find but I don't think that you can make
it in any way precise right and and
averages usually do that does then don't
work well with what our conversation
right so I don't see the distinction
that you can state okay
okay so this was our algorithm which
roughly boys novelist few things you
know we start with something for us it's
a big one
increase the resistance system although
for a distributed okay so now this was
the this was a skeleton and now we know
how to feel the best so now one thing is
that now we won't ever let our distances
are both exactly as ways in a bit and
the other thing is that you know well
are we just know that we now just need
to repeat it at most robots four times
and the way we get the answer is
actually taking the average of all that
becomes rows of indices and clearly by
what I just said you know that you know
this algorithm it works and it gives us
some sort of solution into Mexico in
telling which is roughly the row times n
over epsilon squared so this is number
of iterations and you know till that end
time is a depended it for the
probability each of this logic of
oxidation too much wrong of course you
know when you look at this anytime there
is one big question is that if the
question is how big this you're gonna be
because for now we just say in terms of
robin puri we don't know what it could
be so now to really finish the medicine
is I would we need to again some good
bound to be agreed to be able to save it
yukkuri in terms of Excel so the
question is to decide the question that
it boils down to this is the pollak so
you know well we have our
and the question is you know if I know
worse it's over all possible graphs now
in all most businesses know how deep can
this in this overview how can have equal
to flow on that particular identical
together
and you know if you think about this
question then the answer would be not to
both because in general row can be
better okay it can be as long as they
know they essentially can stop because
you know if listen to the arbitrary what
you can do is that you can dress you
know we just put some very small
resistance of one it all on one on one
exit place SVT and then of course the if
it will be very small compared to the
other distances then of course the flow
will be in the magnetic of room we
incentivize to put all the flow on this
one edge anyone with a very very bad
copper form okay you will get the offer
for five star which would lead partner
there's a clean enough for another
because it depends on the value but the
from a four unit capacity is at most n
so to another so you N squared but
definitely nothing that you will be
happy okay that's a problem but
fortunately there's an easy fix
so what you just do is that you know
whatever you are free we want to compute
Eureka flows you don't do it by grass
you're taking two distances and packing
it into your electrical from solar what
you actually do you regularize this this
before before passing them all so
essentially you just take the order
resistance but then you add you mix in
the need for distribution includes you
you mean
a bit of of the infant solution to it
and this way you just make sure that no
resistance is too small compared to the
average okay and now once you put it in
rotation then you can actually show that
you know that's you can show that it's
never a bigger than squirrel of an open
set okay and initially I was planning to
actually show this it's sort of hard to
close and insensate explains what's
going on and what we want to actually do
that occur first what is magical about
them but I guess I was skipping because
I am running behind a time so you know
you can just trust me on that and in the
next lecture that will be again a
similar proof happening so then you can
understand why if you know why okay the
confusion is that the squared open is
coming from the fact that you know
electrical flows are minimizing so if
all since you're wrong the leathercraft
rocks are minimizing the sum of squares
of this growth okay and you can prove
that the sum of the squares of the cross
which is the energy can never be undone
in Internet or MX whatever M is close to
N and then you just know that each of
this term is at most
well I suppose any so that you take a
square root of website gives you so stop
it is the key reason why you want to dig
around that's why the eternal to
musician into due to the square of the
scope of entry but again in the lecture
tree I will again I'd go over and prove
where you know
but decision there is history
okay is that fine with destruction
excavation so so once you know but then
essentially none 110-pound overall you
know that you were to get use it this
until it becomes all good okay and this
is less than any other equals zero we
did all this work to exactly meet this
energy in order to do better okay so how
can you actually actually beat this
entity as a barrier here what's that
book there are you not curious at the
follow so first of all you know what we
know is that the running time you see
the naked by the number of let this have
a rope that tells us how many
difficulties we have to do okay
and you know we just wanna just claim
that you can prove okay so of especially
is how can we improve this part is if we
approve this but we are done we are
trusted we are just getting into about
that everything flows unfortunately we
can't really improve this bound and Kure
the reason why so nothing that your bra
just looks like that so it has roughly
this SMT in the strap is square root of
n pops of square root of any length and
then there is just one edge a short
nothing connects present okay so what
can you say about this girl
so really the value of talk slow in this
graph is roughly score Cavell because
each path takes that is able to support
over here a university but then if you
look at any lateral then what will
happen is that the effectiveness of this
one edge would be comparable to the a
theory center this whole system is part
just
and of course fanaticism
so definitely what will happen is that
after we've roughly sent half of the
flow although these faster half of this
flow of this edge so this will really
give us a skirt of what is it here the
essence our own one so we don't even
have to do a rotation ok so that's the
problem so we can't really prove this no
it looks ok then
well what do people actually is just
look at this example is back example
again so how about just removing the
short cutting edge from there it's well
the maxvill will not change much right
we remove one edge but the body of max
rome is square root of n so we just
remove once whatever sort of an
attraction today as well and we are
hoping that minus epsilon approximation
when I tell you is what is taken to be
suppose it so clearly we can't afford to
move is essentially transfer too much
but on the family in atmosphere remove
this edge then the behavior of the
reticle flow the residual graph becomes
much much much nicer Troy and Africa
flow becomes a Knoxville graduate ok so
this is the observation and no it works
for this particular case but can we turn
it into a general like arrival awkward
and of course I wouldn't be asking this
question if it wasn't rocky the idea is
the following so what we do we just make
our Oracle self and source some smaller
we've robbed right ok so we just have
some our idea or or crime that you would
like to enforce and what we just do it
we just notify our Oracle this
competition has been affirmed it is
falling way so you know whatever you
computer throw we look at this room and
if we see that so edges throwing more
than throw prime what we do is just
remove this edge forever from our graph
and recompute this room okay
and we keep doing this until we get a
satisfying floor until we disconnected
Cynthia that is a catastrophe and that
you just keep doing this and only when
we see a flaw of the actual satisfies
this constraint of kindness the doesn't
have any flow you can prop right we
actually pass it on to our okay so
what's happening so sorry we're just
trying to vary that very very simplistic
way of enforcing good focuses whenever
we see another commission plan we just
remove this edge forever and repeat the
flow and we are hoping that at some
point we get the right okay so clearly
you know what we observe is that if this
Satechi always ends up working so
viewing always no one's gonna look too
many iterations we get and function if
you like then clearly you know the hall
we want to be category updates framework
with all of us to conclude that you know
we have an oracle of food for our pride
so we will get the running time is
proportional to Rho prime as opposed to
okay but of course you know this is this
is a bit tricky because you know the
question is what is the right city go
for crime to make all it work because
you know on one type of course we won't
drop right to be as small as possible
because this will govern number of
iterations of medical equipment we have
but other hand you know if we put no
crime too small as if you prove put rope
rat to be one then all you will ever do
is we'll keep removing edges from the
graph and you will never
you know what you are either way you
look at it make sure don't be too
aggressive in your choice of program and
you know it turns out that the sweet
spots will actually set the road right -
sort of to the balance out is to go
there things you have to do one person
again I am sorry
thanks for more questions I have time
for questions talking maybe I shouldn't
have said that
it's nothing let me just sit on it
the key reason that allows you to do
this we were to do this it's just you in
this example so what you can't prove is
that whenever you remove a dress that
throw a lot in your in your electrical
flow then on one hand they don't change
much so much but they don't return back
so much but what they do they increase
the energy of the flow I hello okay so
so that's the way that so that's the way
you will make progress so roughly
speaking what you literally is that you
introduce a potential function which is
does the energy of the electrical flow
with rest of your current resources and
you know whenever you remove an extra so
that business becomes infinity and this
is well and this will be your potential
function and then what your show is what
you get from that initially this energy
will not be too small okay
and a also it can become too large so
essentially unless there is some safety
code it is so unless you don't remove
too many edges from your graph that
there is no honorable develop energy you
can ever
so we have a potential of biscuit lower
bound and upper bound and now also what
you know is that you know the way to be
ready for it update bit of money for his
distances make them always good okay so
it's the trigger obviously around
resistance is we never decrease then so
because of that we know that the special
part to this energy is never an amusing
Peter okay so it's always a case of
felony growth so generally we understood
what it is there's two bonds that make
our energy be a good potential function
so it's always moved on one direction it
doesn't have to be too small and a bit
too much so the only missing piece that
we need to shower or I will show it back
to you can show it is that removable and
overflowing entry the ends up you know
increasing the energy ok essentially
once you put all the math on it once you
just do the order completion you realize
that the Seneca fro privateer a fee and
to the 1/3 is the this is there is an
example that gives you the entry one
that with photos behavior is so it looks
something like from memory but roughly
speaking you have a path
so we have a path of its
and then and now what you do mean you
have to put some sort of Edna so
essentially what you do is just you put
short cutting edges okay and then what
will be happening is that when you
computer sorry that's that's n to the
one terms like so the max-flow
body-centered one because this path is
able to support sure just aren't they it
doesn't matter they'll always think like
just hard I'll just make this path for
so long but this is human okay so what
will happen is that when you complete
control but at first this one it
actually will get flow and with but then
this edge will get and you will keep
removing this end
well one big fingers force apart you can
make it if you were able to compute if
you were able to simulate dials
efficient only always enforce that he
just goes direction you go and actually
exactly but actually a graph like that
supposedly the crucial your life in fact
that is connected
oh well the moving images the gorillas
to the business community so can this
Oracle itself be seen as solving another
optimization problem that now the
capacity constraints are low crying
instead of Pro and it's solving that by
a multiplicative update method well the
penalty is very severe
no not really because then the
contenders will come up okay
actually yes but like but the point is
that when you do that you will get the
same algorithm like the updates will be
the same because in the updates you are
really normalizing when the worst is
over for it so today so especially like
yes that's true but it's not the
different algorithms it's exactly the
same algorithm just like it doesn't it
so the column like nephew sit there
saying it like no actually it to do in
the divorce because it the colors will
be very small because once you have no
unique capacities and you also normalize
your updates by that then everything
that would have very small very tiny
updates it could be much more such we
know so the others will be almost the
same except they will be scaled also so
when you have this updates there are
like episode now it's just raw capacity
then you would also have the capacity
here okay and now we would sort of slow
down so like the same answers it so you
should take the same assets like so
there's it does auntie classic as
opposed to scale equal resistances by
just you in so you moving train the
answers but the answers for like most of
the uh no sorry this will work we also
of course but this will just just
absorbed escape to sorry so my answer is
it story so it will you just get the
same a rule yes like you just get same
algorithm because you like the answers
would be the same no so the connected is
now something a slightly different
problem then it is it is the average
flow constraint and then the capacity
constraint on each edge is now Rho prime
instead of one well okay so the point is
that the whole thing could work
essentially the same if all you just it
is whenever you have an address
capacity well bigger than propriety just
multiply this by two which essentially
could be like essentially what I could
have done I could not I could not feel
like I could avoid this removal up step
and just let it actually pass it to the
ways they would do the right thing but
they would multiply this edge by song by
some constant fraction and you know that
is the world sensationalize it will have
to again they compose it went on into
this analysis but yes if I didn't do if
I do implement the removal of the edges
myself I will just let the I figure I'll
do it cool
it's just that this isn't a nice to us
have to separate this movie said about
about the we can it get worse if you
start from a better
yes Pacific excellent question and I
don't know any answers to it like I
think you would expect your whiz to be
bad drug the whole iteration it was
roughly what corresponds to is that you
are setting some waking on your edges
and you ask for minimizing this average
okay so we never address will get a lot
of a lot of the way they will behave
well because you will force them to pee
well but the edges that but then it
always leaves some edges to can a bit
less than average sugar then average
weight and so the result of this would
be that this edges would be more likely
to be like so I think of it I ended it
observes reminisce but the way I view
this combative I think it always is
always one edge with lead to trouble but
can it get worse
that's concert you stuck in opponents
yes I think it can make it worse and I
think I think if there was I haven't
tested it but okay there is nothing I
can see that would prevent a little from
getting worse is that because it doesn't
seem to be connected to you know how
good your current solution is to the
mass flow because it always just tries
to find the bottleneck
- wait the buffoon next well but then
the leaves everything else with her have
to be like once you are doing well on
some edges they develop they get smaller
weight in the interspersing petition so
they are no more likely to 3d combat
what would happen is exactly so the
point is that I sort of we chose the we
chose we chose the dress for such a way
that now always the the upper most
entries doesn't evolve our transport but
all the others not so I think it's kinda
like my competition sort of Whitewood
are very bad but I think what what
happens that all of them will be dead
and we will just remove all them in one
step
Rosabelle happened was that if you have
world
okay no they all would pepper and his
one carrots right so yes
so
yeah then let's take a five this is
actually in your senior Sam I'm not sure
them okay I would have to think about it
they were still yeah well let's take it
off my mic well it's okay so yeah so
this is the algorithm
the cause of the problem and contribute
badly to the which are also the portions
of the problem should be instant
yes well it's sort of its first like
sauce every what you can that we do get
a lot is what you can show is that okay
so it's okay sorry sorry
it can it work so there's one missing
it's like so yes it's true that I rely
on the fact that you know if something
isn't over okay
so it works for any Oracle that ends up
to minimize the quadratic function the
same sanity works because the point that
you are likely to have to keep in mind
here is that we're using an 30s if I
remove an individual wrench it changes
the object is not much but then it says
the energy you know so it has enough
energy that so I think what you can do
this is actually something I was just
playing with the other day I think you
know you can define an LP Immunization
like prominence with your arm is given
by an immunization so for sure you can
use it for sure that's what should I
have to prove it because you know energy
is just one of these but you can the way
you prove it is that by 30 into one so
we can look at it do one of any healthy
immunization and see what you get here
and I think what you should be able to
put this well it is something like that
you know if you are using help
Indonesian Markham then they're using
this technique you can get on the end to
the one over P iteration
so for anyone but but this is something
I have not but it but this just made my
intuition able to see it but that's the
interesting thing is that it's distance
sort of trying to understand the whole
picture or what happens like anything
this Rover spoon over epsilon squared
result it works for this electrical at
weakest condition never is that you just
assume that there is some so the
question is what are the stronger
condition on the world or after that
you've any false this is one way of this
is the analysis are given by minimizing
so help you know so I think that's so I
think that this design is more
experimental x-wing duster nobody talked
about the width of this this thing will
come back again and then he says that
because this actually applies to all
there are posters can identify let's
give you Charles address but you can do
something to them and not change the
color much but here so in this problem I
actually this is something
it's exactly how love set up to this
like so much summer I see does it play
in many many scenarios when you use the
detective unit you change about a little
bit and and approves of n just a lot and
again this is for people but if I sculpt
sake can see that I think this is a
therapist but I just haven't found
exactly